>> Tucker: WE JUST SHOWED YOU
THE FIRST 20 MINUTES OF OUR
INTERVIEW A FEW HOURS AGO WITH
TONY, WELL KNOWN INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS MAN WHO WAS ASKED BY
THE BIDEN FAMILY TO DO BUSINESS
WITH THEM IN CHINA.
HE MET WITH THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT TWO SEPARATE
TIMES AND THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
CHINA BUSINESS DEAL.
THIS INFORMATION HAS BEEN OUT
FOR SEVERAL WEEKS, THE HANDS OF
A NUMBER DIFFERENT OF NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE REASON YOU
ARE HEARING IT FOR THE FIRST
TIME IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
RESOLUTELY IGNORED IT AND TO
SUPPRESS THE STORY.
THERE’S AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
DETAIL THAT NO ONE HAS REFUTED
BECAUSE IT’S REAL.
WHAT WAS NOTABLE THAT JOE BIDEN
DIDN’T DENY ANY SPECIFICS ABOUT
HIS CONNECTIONS TO THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY AND HIS FAMILY
DOING BUSINESS THERE AND HE
HIMSELF PARTICIPATED IN THAT
BUSINESS.
INSTEAD, DISMISS THE ENTIRE
STORY OUT OF HAND AND SUGGESTED
THAT TONY BOBULINSKI WHO WAS A
VETERAN, FORMER NAVAL OFFICER
WAS PART OF A RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN AIMED AT
THIS COUNTRY.
HE CITED A LETTER FROM FOR
FORMER NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE
FOLKS FROM ALMOST ALL OF THEM
PARTISANS, EVERY ONE OF THEM A
LIAR, NONE OF THEM HOW TO
DIRECTLY ASSESS THE INFORMATION
AND NOT ONE OF THEM CALLED TONY
BOBULINSKI.
JOE BIDEN SAID THAT ON STAGE SO
WHEN WE SPOKE, WE ASKED HIM HIS
REACTION TO THAT AND HERE’S WHAT
HE SAID.
TELL ME ABOUT THE CONVERSATION,
WHAT DID HE SAY TO YOU?
>> THERE WERE TEN PEOPLE RUNNING
AROUND GETTING SOMETHING TO
DRINK AND WE WERE BACKSTAGE IN A
CRAMPED SPACE AND JUST ASKED HOW
I DID AND WHAT I THOUGHT OF THE
SPEECH I DID A GREAT JOB IN THE
SPEECH AND OBVIOUSLY IT’S A VERY
SERIOUS THING WE SHOULD ALL BE
WORKING TOGETHER TO SOLVE, LOST
A SISTER-IN-LAW TO CANCER AND
JUST SORT OF ASKED ME TO KEEP AN
EYE ON HIS SON AND HIS BROTHER.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK
HE MEANT BY THAT?
>> I THINK HE WAS CONSCIOUS OF
THINGS AND I CAN’T SPEAK FOR
HIM, I WOULD LOVE FOR HIM TO GO
ON RECORD AS I REFERENCED
EARLIER, ONLY SITTING HERE
BECAUSE NOT ONLY HAVE THEY NOT
GONE ON RECORD, THEY’VE DENIED
IT AND HAVE TARRED MY FAMILY
NAME, LONG HISTORY OF SERVING
THIS COUNTRY AND HAVE OTHER
CONGRESSMEN NOW TALKING ABOUT
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
>> THIS WHOLE SMEAR ON JOE BIDEN
COMES FROM THE KREMLIN.
>> I HELD A TOP-SECRET
CLEARANCE, AND SERVE THIS
COUNTRY FOR FOUR YEARS AT ONE OF
THE MOST ELITE ENVIRONMENTS IN
THE WORLD, AND TO HAVE A
CONGRESSMEN OUT THERE SPEAKING
ABOUT RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION OR
JOE BIDEN HAD A PUBLIC DEBATE
REFERENCING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION WHEN HE KNOWS HE
SAT FACE-TO-FACE WITH ME
TRAVELED AROUND THE WORLD WITH
HIS SON AND HIS BROTHER TO SAY
THAT AN ASSOCIATE THAT WITH MY
NAME IS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING TO
ME.
>> Tucker: DID YOU COMPLAIN
ABOUT THAT?
TO SUGGEST THAT YOU WERE
COMMITTING TREASON FOR PART OF A
FOREIGN ATTACK ON OUR DEMOCRACY
WHICH IS HOW THEY CHARACTERIZED
IT.
IT IS SUCH A SERIOUS AND I THINK
UNFAIR CHARGE.
>> YOU’RE EXACTLY EXACTLY RIGHT,
PUBLICLY ACCUSING ME OF TREASON,
TREATING ME LIKE I’M
INSIGNIFICANT FOR THE 50 YEARS
OF HISTORY THAT MY FAMILY SERVE
THIS COUNTRY IS INSIGNIFICANT
AND THAT’S WHY AM SITTING HERE,
I ASSURE YOU THIS IS THE LAST
PLACE I WANT TO BE RIGHT NOW IN
THE LAST THING I WANT TO BE
DOING RIGHT NOW, BUT I FEEL LIKE
AS A PATRIOTIC DUTY TO THIS
COUNTRY AND EVERY AMERICAN
CITIZEN TO GO ON RECORD AND
DEFINE THE FACTS FOR THEM AND
LET THEM DO THEIR OWN WORK, LET
THEM DECIDE HOW THEY VIEW THOSE
BUT FOR THE BIDEN FAMILY TO DENY
THESE FACTS AND THEN NOT ONLY
DENY THEM, COULD HAVE JUST SAID
NO COMMENT.
THEY BROUGHT IN RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION AND BASICALLY
ASSOCIATED MY NAME WITH THAT
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING
TO ME AND I HAD TO GO ON THE
RECORD.
LAST WEEKEND, I WAS IN VIRGINIA,
MY SISTER-IN-LAW PASSED AWAY
AROUND SATURDAY MORNING.
SPENT 27 YEARS AND JUST RETIRED
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE ME DEALING
WITH THAT AND THE TRAGEDY OF
THAT.
WHEN I SAW ADAM SCHIFF GO ON
RECORD TALKING ABOUT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION AFTER THIS EMAIL
HAD BEEN POSTED ONLINE BY
"THE NEW YORK POST" AND REMEMBER
THAT EMAIL WAS TO ME, IT WAS TO
ME STATING THAT I WAS GOING TO
BE THE CEO OF THIS ENTERPRISE.
SO I TOLD HIM THAT THAT
STATEMENT IS RETRACTED BY
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF BY MIDNIGHT
ON SUNDAY THAT WAS GOING ON
RECORD AND DISPOSING ALL THE
FACTS OF THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT, TO THE AMERICAN
CITIZEN ENDS OF THE WORLD.
I WAS HOPING THE BIDENS WOULD DO
THE RIGHT THING OR HE WOULD
RETRACT HIS STATEMENT BUT I
COULD NOT ALLOW ANOTHER MINUTE
OR HOUR OR DAY OF MY FAMILIES
NAME TO BE ASSOCIATED OR MUDDIED
UP AROUND RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
SO EVEN AS I SIT HERE TODAY, I
WOULD ASK THEM TO GO ON RECORD
AND STOP USING MY NAME OR
ASSOCIATING IT WITH RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
IT’S DISGUSTING.
>> Tucker: SO THIS IS THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE BIDEN
FAMILY, SO YOU SET THIS TO HIM.
I JUST WANT THEM TO RETRACT THE
ACCUSATION THAT I’M AN
INSTRUMENT OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> UNDER A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
STRESS, A WIFE AND A CHILD AND
SAID LET ME MAKE SOME CALLS,
CALL GEORGE AND SEE WHAT I CAN
DO BUT HE SORT OF PRESENTED IT
AS IF THAT’S GOING TO BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO GET DONE
AND I’M NOT NAIVE.
I KNOW THAT’S NOT IMPOSSIBLE.
THAT’S A SINGLE PHONE CALL FROM
JOE BIDEN TO ADAM SCHIFF SAYING
GO ON RECORD AND RETRACT YOUR
STATEMENT.
HE GOT OVER YOUR SKIS AND WHEN
THE STATEMENT WASN’T RETRACTED,
READY TO GO ON RECORD AND HOW
THAT RECORD WAS WAS WILLING TO
GO IN FRONT OF ANY SENATOR, AND
A CONGRESSMAN, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, THE FBI OR SIT HERE
WITH YOU AND BASICALLY PROVIDE
THE FACTS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND LET THEM MAKE THEIR
DECISION.
THIS ISN’T A POLITICAL FOCUS OF
MINE.
PEOPLE WERE ACCUSING MY FAMILY
OF TREASON AFTER I SERVE THIS
COUNTRY AND DEFENDED THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THE REASON YOU
WOUND UP HERE IN THIS INTERVIEW
AND I JUST WANT TO AFFIRM.
IS BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE TOLD YOUR
STORY.
SO WERE YOU SURPRISED GIVEN THE
TROVE OF DOCUMENTS YOU HAVE,
GIVEN THE CREDIBILITY BUT I
THINK IS APPARENT THAT YOU HAVE
THAT NO OTHER NEWS ORGANIZATION
TOOK THE TIME TO UNPACK THE
STORY?
>> SURPRISES PROBABLY
UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE YEAR,
SHOCKED BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT IF THIS WAS MY WORD
AGAINST JIM BIDEN, HUNTER BIDEN,
AND JOE BIDEN.
THAT WOULD BE A SLIPPERY SLOPE,
NOT SOMETHING I WOULD TAKE THE
PERSONAL FAMILY RISK ON IT BUT I
PROVIDED MORE DOCUMENTS AND
FACTS THAT VALIDATE TIMES,
MEETINGS, WHO PARTICIPATED.
THAT WAS GENERATED BY SOMEBODY
ELSE SENT TO ME.
WASN’T ME GENERATING THESE TEXT
MESSAGES I PROVIDED OR HUNTER
BIDEN IN THE FIRST PERSON, ROB
WALKER IN THE FIRST PERSON, IT’S
NOT ME GENERATING THE TEXT
MESSAGES, IT’S THEM SPEAKING, SO
YOU CAN INTERVIEW THEM.
THE FBI CAN INTERVIEW THEM, OUR
GOVERNMENT CAN INTERVIEW THEM,
BUT I WAS SHOCKED THAT NOT ONLY
THE MEDIA IS NOT ONLY DISCUSSING
THIS, THEY ARE GOING TO THE
OTHER EXTREME DISMISSING IT AS
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
WE WENT THROUGH THREE YEARS OF
EVERY DAY RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA.
IT’S JUST ABSURD.
THE COLD WAR IS OVER.
>> Tucker: AND THEY’RE SAYING
IT ABOUT YOUR FAMILY.
THE BIDEN FAMILY KNEW THAT YOU
WERE GOING PUBLIC WITH THIS AND
YOU SPOKE TO ROB WALKER ABOUT
IT, THE SELF-DESCRIBED BIDEN
FAMILY REPRESENTATIVE.
WHAT WAS HIS RESPONSE WHEN YOU
LET HIM KNOW THAT YOU WERE GOING
PUBLIC WITH THIS?
>> TRYING TO COACH ME, TRYING TO
SAY WE DON’T WANT TO DO THAT, WE
DON’T WANT PRESS TRUCKS OUT IN
FRONT OF OUR HOUSE AND WE HAVE
TO MOVE BECAUSE IT’S MY JOB AND
ALL OF THAT, I’M NOT TRYING TO
CAUSE ANY HARM TO ANYONE IN THIS
SITUATION LET ALONE ROB WALKER
AND HIS FAMILY, BUT BASICALLY,
HIS POSITION WAS IF YOU GO ON
RECORD, YOU WILL BURY ALL OF US.
>> IF HE DOESN’T COME OUT ON
RECORD, I AM PROVIDING THE FACT.
>> Tucker: WHAT WAS YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> I WAS FOCUSED ON PUSHING
THESE GUYS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING, TO DEMONSTRATE AN OUNCE
OF INTEGRITY IN FRONT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ALL KNOW THE FACTS.
I LIVED THE FACTS AND ALL THE
FACTS ARE EXTREMELY WELL
DOCUMENTED.
I’M IRRELEVANT IN THIS
DISCUSSION SO I CAN WRITE OFF IN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN READ
THESE TEXTS AND LISTEN TO THE
RECORDING, THE LEGAL DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE EXECUTED AND THEY CAN
FORM THEIR OWN CONCLUSION.
THEY DON’T NEED ME TO FORM THE
CONCLUSION FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: GIVE US A SENSE OF
YOUR CONTACTS WITH HUNTER BIDEN.
A LOT OF THIS IS COMPLEX, AND
THIS IS TELEVISION SO WE ARE NOT
PUTTING EVERYTHING WE HAVE ON
THIS, BUT FOR THOSE WHO MIGHT
SUSPECT YOU DIDN’T REALLY HAVE A
LOT OF CONTACT WITH HUNTER
BIDEN, GIVE US A SENSE OF THE
PLACES YOU HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH HIM AND OVER WHAT TIME
FRAME.
>> OBVIOUSLY AS WE ALREADY
DISCUSSED THROUGHOUT 2015 AND
2016 WHILE JOE IS STILL THE
SITTING VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THESE GUYS HAD
BEEN DOING EXTENSIVE WORK AROUND
THE WORLD IN PLACES LIKE
LUXEMBOURG, ROMANIA THAT I WAS
BEING MADE AWARE OF THAT I
OBVIOUSLY HADN’T COME OFF THE
BENCH AND AGREED TO BE PART OF
THIS.
>> Tucker: I HAVE TO ASK, THEY
DON’T SPEAK ANY OF THESE
LANGUAGES, NONE OF THEM HAS ANY
RECORD OF SUCCESS IN BUSINESS OR
A BACKGROUND, WHY WOULD THEY BE
DOING BUSINESS THERE?
>> BECAUSE THEY HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS ON THE BIDEN NAME
THEY ARE ABLE TO SET UP MEETINGS
AND GET PEOPLE TO JUMP THROUGH
HOOPS AND AN INTEREST TO GARNER
FAVOR WITH THE SITTING
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
>> Tucker: SO IT LOOKS LIKE
THAT’S A LEGITIMATE BUSINESS
GUY, SOMEONE WHO IS FLUENT IN
THE ANGUISH.
>> TRAVELED AROUND THE WORLD FOR
DECADES, VERY LOW PROFILE
INDIVIDUAL, AND IS SHORT AND IS
A LEGITIMATE AS THEY COME.
>> Tucker: HUNTER BIDEN AND
JIM BIDEN HAVE A WELL-DOCUMENTED
DECADES LONG, LONG RECORD OF
BUSINESS DISASTERS, DID YOU GET
IN A SENSE OF EITHER ONE OF
THESE GUYS MOLLIFIED TO BE
CONDUCTING THIS KIND OF
BUSINESS?
>> THE ONLY QUALIFICATION THEY
HAD WAS THE BIDEN NAME.
>> Tucker: BUT THEY SEEM TO
HAVE PARLAYED THAT INTO QUITE A
FEW DEALS IN QUITE A FEW
COUNTRIES AND I INTERRUPTED YOU,
SO CONTINUE WITH WHERE THEY WERE
DOING THIS DEAL.
>> SO WHEN I DECIDED TO COME OFF
THE BENCH AND ENTERTAIN THE CEO
OF THE HOLDINGS, WAS BROUGHT UP
TO SPEED ON THE WORK THEY WERE
DOING IN LUXEMBOURG, FRANCE,
ROMANIA, KAZAKHSTAN, AND STUFF
LIKE THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS ALL
GOING TO BE INTEGRATED INTO
THOSE HOLDINGS, SO U.S. TO THE
EXTENT THAT I SPENT TIME WITH
HUNTER BIDEN.
I PERSONALLY WAS IN BUCHAREST,
ROMANIA, WITH HUNTER BIDEN, JIM
BIDEN, ROB WALKER, I WAS IN
MONACO FOR THE ANNUAL GRAND PRIX
THERE, SUPPOSED TO SIT WITH
HUNTER BIDEN, I MET HIM ON THE
PATIO OF HIS HOTEL AND I SAT
THERE AND WAITED FOR TWO HOURS,
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW ANGRY
AND FRUSTRATED AFTER SITTING
THERE FOR TWO HOURS WAITING FOR
HIM WITHOUT A TEXT OR PHONE CALL
TO LET ME KNOW I CAN’T MAKE IT
OR AM TIED UP IN A TEXT THAT I
THINK YOU GUYS ARE AWARE OF AND
SAW THE NEXT DAY, HE
AGGRESSIVELY COMES BACK AT ME
THAT HE COULDN’T ATTEND THE
MEETING, THAT HE HIMSELF SET UP.
I STEPPED AWAY FROM FAMILY AND
FRIENDS, AND NOT THAT I WAS ON
WITH MY FRIENDS TO GO SIT WITH
HIM FOR A COUPLE OF HOURS, AND
HE IS EFFECTIVELY SCREAMING INTO
THE PHONE THAT HE COULD NOT PICK
UP THE PHONE AND TEXT ME BECAUSE
HE WAS WITH THE UKRAINIANS AND
THE FOUNDER OF BURISMA AND WAS
FIGHTING FOR THE ONLY INCOME HE
HAS ON A DEAL THAT APPARENTLY HE
NEGOTIATED.
I HAD NO EXPOSURE TO THAT DEAL.
I’M NOT AWARE OF ANY OF THE
PARTICULARS OF THAT DEAL.
I JUST KNOW FOR A FACT THERE IS
A DEAL BECAUSE HUNTER BIDEN TOLD
ME THERE WAS THE TEXT THAT I
THINK YOU GUYS HAVE ANY WILL
SHOW TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT’S NOT MY JOB TO DETERMINE
WHAT THAT DEAL IS, I WILL LEAVE
THAT UP TO THE FBI OR THE SENATE
AND CONGRESS TO FIGURE THAT OUT.
>> Tucker: I JUST WANT TO
RESTATE THIS, YOU ARE NOT A
GRIFTER, NOT SOMEONE WHO IS
SELLING ACCESS, A LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS MAN WHO HAS DONE DEALS
IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
SO I JUST WANT YOU TO ASSESS
ONCE MORE IS THERE ANYTHING
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN’S PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE, PERSONAL
QUALIFICATIONS THAT WOULD
JUSTIFY HIM DOING A DEAL IN
KAZAKHSTAN?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THE ONLY THING THAT HE HAD WAS
THE BIDEN FAMILY NAME AND THE
FACT THAT HIS FATHER AT
ONE POINT OBVIOUSLY WAS A
SITTING VICE PRESIDENT AND
POTENTIALLY WOULD RUN AS A
FUTURE PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: IT SOUNDS LIKE A
REMARKABLY AMBITIOUS
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS PROGRAM
THEY HAD RUNNING.
>> EXTENSIVELY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A SMALL
POINT THAT I CAN’T GET OVER.
SO YOU’VE SAW A NUMBER OF
REPORTERS SAY AGAIN IN AN EFFORT
TO BACK AWAY YOUR STORY, YOUR
TESTIMONY ON THIS THAT THE
CHAIRMAN REFERRED TO IN A BUNCH
OF THESE EMAILS WAS NOT
JOE BIDEN WHO WAS IN FACT THE
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA.
WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE REFER TO THE
CHAIRMAN THINKS THIS IN THE
CHAIRMAN THINKS THAT, THEY ARE
THINKING ABOUT CHINA AND NOT
JOE BIDEN.
SO HERE IS A TEXT MESSAGE YOU
RECEIVED FROM HUNTER BIDEN TO
YOU.
BOTH JAMES’ LAWYERS IN MY
CHAIRMAN GAVE AN EMPHATIC NO, I
THINK WE SHOULD ALL MEET IN
ROMANIA ON TUESDAY NEXT WEEK.
SO YOU’RE HEARING REPORTERS SAY
THAT CHAIRMAN WAS THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
HERE YOU HAVE ROB WALKER
RESPONDING TO YOU, CLEARLY SOME
CONFUSION OVER THIS WHEN HE SAID
HIS CHAIRMAN, HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT HIS DAD.
>> CORRECT, TO CHAIRMAN IN THIS
STORY, THE CHAIRMAN OF CFC AND
THAT TEXT FROM HUNTER BIDEN, IT
WAS NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
CHAIRMAN OF CFC AND WHAT HUNTER
IS REFERENCING THERE AS HE SPOKE
WITH HIS FATHER AND HIS FATHER
IS GIVING AN EMPHATIC NO TO
PUTTING PROPER GOVERNANCE IN
PLACE AROUND THE HOLDINGS.
>> Tucker: SO JOE BIDEN IS
VETOING YOUR PLAN FOR PUTTING
STRICTER GOVERNANCE IN THE
COMPANY.
AND IT’S RIGHT HERE IN THE
EMAIL.
>> I WANT TO BE VERY CAREFUL IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT ME WRITING THAT,
THAT IS NOT ME CLAIMING THAT,
THAT’S HIM WRITING ON HIS OWN
PHONE TYPING AND THAT I SPOKE
WITH MY CHAIRMAN REFERENCING HIS
FATHER.
THE WORLD THINKS THAT THAT IS
NOT HIS FATHER, THAN HUNTER
BIDEN WOULD COME FORWARD A AND G
ON RECORD AND SAY TO THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU HAVE ROB